[Music]
today's question comes from rachel in
idaho i listen to your show a lot and
often hear you in the team talk about
contentment which is very important
currently my husband and i are in baby
steps four five and six and happy with
our lives and house however our dream is
to have a house with some acreage for a
small farm we're 29 and 37 how can we
mentally balance contentment versus our
future goals
what do you think man well i know john
you're you're a big fan of uh you know
living off the fat of the land and all
that you live in the middle of nowhere
with no cell service so this is more you
guys align with this dream right and
you've always wanted to have a big plot
of land and i love that we've got a
place where you can plug in your tesla
there we go thank you john but she's
asking how do we balance contentment we
want this land we're happy with where we
live here's our future goal we're trying
to invest safe for the kids college we
want to pay the house off but we also
want this next thing yeah and so
balancing that they're asking mentally
balancing it financially it's pretty
simple you get these plates spinning get
investing put a little away for college
let's pay off the house and as you build
that equity you'll be able to roll that
over as you start to look for this new
piece of land in the future
and that takes some patience when it
comes to
i guess mentally i don't know if i would
say it like that but when it comes to
just being present where you are and
having big dreams
uh one of the criticisms i get when i'm
meeting with people behind closed doors
i'll travel across the country meet with
leaders and business owners and we'll
sit down and we'll talk through being
well what that looks like and how to
create wellness in your home and how
executives stay well and the pushback
generally comes from what am i supposed
to do then if all these things i'm doing
in my life are killing me am i supposed
to just not run a business anymore am i
supposed to not be ambitious anymore
and i always tell them no absolutely not
in fact the opposite
my two little kids are growing up in the
systems that these guys are building
these men and women are creating and
running right now right i need them to
be ambitious we got big problems we've
got to solve
i also need them to know
that that extra zero that they earn
will not
make up for the fact that their dad left
right
getting this new piece of acreage isn't
gonna suddenly be the place where your
marriage materializes into peaceful and
joy and hope and all this great stuff
you're still gonna have fights when you
live on this big property your marriage
is still gonna be hard and so dream big
and
take concrete steps like you're talking
about to see those dreams through and
know full well those dreams won't fix me
it won't solve my marriage won't make my
kids suddenly fill in the plank right
unless you are in
um you are in situations where people
are abjectly not safe right then getting
them out of safety definitely helps
everything right yeah so it's being able
to balance let's do the small things to
make sure our marriage is whole to make
sure we're great parents we're plugged
in and we're connected we love our small
community and we're doing this thing
because we want we want this life not
because this life is going to do
something for us right and we tend to
cash in our present day joy for this
this
mystical joy that's going to come down
the road and doesn't work like that
right
you've heard the old saying like
wherever you show up you're going to go
too right you go with you
and part of this is we just live in this
microwave culture where it's like i want
it now two hour delivery now i can't
wait two days and so part of that bleeds
into our life goals and we're looking
for shortcuts now we go well we could
just take on the bigger mortgage we
could do the heloc we can borrow from
our 401k and you're looking for all
these terrible shortcuts to get you to
where you want to go
but if you just sit down on paper and go
all right that new property is going to
cost 500 000
our home is worth 300. what if we get
that paid off in the next three years
then we start saving up we have an extra
2 000 we could buy this thing with cash
6 years from now right and you start to
put that on paper and instead of letting
it deflate you you let it fuel you and
go all right this is what we're going to
be about and it's going to take six
years but guess what you're 29 and 37.
people think it's too late at that like
well i should have had it at 25 right
right
and you look up and you go dude you're
gonna live to be like a thousand with
technology and healthcare these days you
got plenty of time
slow down enjoy the ride smell the roses
and be proud of yourselves where you're
at out of debt completely investing for
the future with financial peace
george when you look down the road for
you what are some things you are excited
about
well as you know john we're ambitious
people my wife works here at ramsey and
so i found that contentment ambition uh
their their next door neighbors and they
can get along peacefully yeah when we
aren't always going what's the next
thing what's the next thing and we have
a tendency to do that i do too i'm very
guilty of this and ramsay's just a very
driven place we're very competitive
we're always focused on goals so what
has helped us is just to sit in silence
and look around and go
this is the house we dreamed about right
five years ago
and this is the life we would have
dreamt about when we were broken and
dead it's very rare that people
recognize they're standing in the middle
of a blessing yes because you look at
your neighbor and like oh man his grass
is a lot greener you go to his yard and
you're like oh his yard actually sucks
it just looks different from the angle i
have this home that you all are living
in is the answer to one of your
grandparents prayers for y'all right
this home you are living in is the
culmination of a bunch of people making
hard choices throughout the years to
move their families across oceans and
across cultures and
for this moment right and there's
something about sitting in that and
saying
huh
all right when you do it without
shortcuts it changes the way you view it
that's right because it's a blessing and
not a curse and we sleep well at night
knowing that we're not over here sitting
with piles of debt trying to live this
facade of a life to impress anyone
that's right every decision i make is
just going i think this is going to
benefit me and my family and we've
earned it and i would recommend anybody
who says hey we want to get a bunch of
land we want to do a tiny house thing we
want to live an event
take a week of your vacation this
upcoming year and go to a dude ranch and
work it right get a van goes go try out
this life before you let it be go milk
some cows there you go before you think
it's gonna solve everything